قبل يومين من تقديمه للمحاكمه ما زال بعض
الغموض يلف قضيه الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب وما سيواجهه خلال المحاكمه وفيما
وصلت اليه القضيه فهناك خمس ملاحظات لما
يتهم به ترامب وما قد يواجهه اولها فان
لائحه ستبقى سريه حتى يمثل امام المحكمه
ما لم يطلب المدعي العام الكشف عنها لا
تفاصيل واضحه عن طبيعه الاتهام الذي
سيواجهه لكن مصادر مطلعه رجحت ان تتضمن
تهما جنائيه التحقيق في السابق كان يركز
على دفع 130 الف دولار قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه باسابيع شراء الصمت بالاموال
يعتبر قضيه قانونيه لكن المخاوف تدور حول
ان تتضمن التهم تزوير سجلات تجاريه
ولاثبات تورط ترامب سيحتاج المدعون اثبات
انه كان متورطا شخصيا فيما اتهموه به
اعترف بالدفع لدانه ومحامه فسر الامر بانه
لحمايه زواجه لكنهم يخشون ان يسعى المدعي
العام للحصول على تهم جنائيه من خلال
تاكيد على ان المدفوعات تنتهك قوانين
الحمله الانتخابيه بطريقه ما تقول اخر
المعلومات ان الرئيس السابق يريد ان يتم
تقييد يديه عند ظهور امام المحكمه معتقدا
انه سيكون استعراضا مهيبا للقوه قوه لا
يريد حتى حاكم ولايه فلوريدا التورته في
مواجهتها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]